[موسيقى]
لذلك اسمي
أبلغ من العمر 21 عامًا وعندما كنت في الثالثة من
عمري ، اجتمعت مع عائلتي
من العراق
شمال العراق وكردستان إلى سويسرا
التي كانت لاجئة وعندما كان عمري 11 عامًا
بدأت الاستثمار في عملة البيتكوين  يعني أنني
نشأت فقيرًا للغاية مع عائلتي في
ظروف سيئة للغاية وأحاول دائمًا إيجاد
بعض الطرق لفعل شيء ما لمساعدة عائلتي.
بمجرد أن
شجعتنا جدتي على احتياجها
لعملية جراحية ولم نتمكن من إرسال أموالها
لأنه لم يكن من الممكن إرسال
أموال من سويسرا إلى كوردستان ،
لا توجد مساحة ائتمان ubs مهما كان الأمر كذلك
عندما كان عمري 11 عامًا كنت
على جهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بي وأنا  googled للحصول على
حل
ووجدت bitcoin أجد
عملة البيتكوين كعملة رقمية وأخبرت حسنًا أنني بحاجة
إلى عملة البيتكوين هذه لإرسالها إلى
جدتي حتى تتمكن من استخدامها في
عمليتها ، لقد قمت ببيع جميع ألعابي في
المشغل في غرفتي
على  خارج الشارع في ipsa في أ
قرية صغيرة في بيرن في سويسرا
أعطت المال لوالدي نقدًا
وبواسطة بطاقات الائتمان الخاصة به وحساب باي بال
على صندوق السلك ، أول 10 عملات بيتكوين لي
مقابل 15 يورو ثم المزيد والمزيد والمزيد
[الموسيقى]
عندما بدأت في فهم البيتكوين أ
أكثر من ذلك بقليل عندما كان عمري 13 عامًا
14 عامًا ، بدأت في
الاهتمام جدًا بتكنولوجيا blockchain
وما وراء التكنولوجيا نفسها
، ثم بدأت في تداول البيتكوين
وشراء وبيع وشراء وبيع ما بين 13 و 17
عامًا.
يدويًا ، ثم قمت
بإنشاء استراتيجيات تداول أوتوماتيكية
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وعندما كان
عمري 21 عامًا ، أنشأت أول
منصة تمكين تشفير في
العالم وعندما كان عمري 21 عامًا أيضًا
اشتريت أول
شركة أوروبية قامت بترميز
العقارات أو من  لا يمكنني تنظيم العقارات ،
وجلب العقارات إلى
تقنية blockchain ، وفي الواقع
اشتريت
الكثير من الشركات واستثمرت ،
فأنا استثمر الكثير من الشركات التي تشارك
كل ما أفعله  حظًا سعيدًا ولكن في الغالب
دائمًا في
يد الله ،
لذا فكل شيء على الله ،
لقد أعطاني هذا ولم يمنحني هذا أي شخص آخر
وما أحاول فعله الآن هو أنني أحاول
مساعدة أي شخص آخر في عائلتي
في العالم الذي أريده  أعط شيئًا ما
الآن أريد أن أهزم الفقر في جميع أنحاء
العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم
أول مرة عندما كنت هنا في الليلة الأولى
كنت ثريًا جديدًا ، أعني أنني ما زلت ثريًا جديدًا ،
ولكن المرة الأولى عندما كنت هنا  لقد
كنت رائعًا ، كل شيء جيدًا أعني أنه بعد
شهر واحد بالنسبة لي ، كان من الطبيعي أن أكون
هنا بشكل عام عندما تصبح غنيًا ،
يكون لديك المزيد من الأصدقاء لديك الكثير من
الفتيات مهما كانت الأشياء من هذا القبيل ولكنها
مزيفة وبعد ذلك تبدأ في أن تكون أكثر
حذراً
لقد تغيرت حياتي بمقدار 180 درجة من قبل عندما
كنت فقيرًا ، ربما رأيت الكثير
من الحياة لدرجة أنني رأيت
القليل فقط الآن أرى هذا وأنت تعلم أنني
لم أكن أعرف أن هناك شيئًا
مثل المنحة القديمة مثل هذا الفندق  لم أكن
أعرف عن هذا الكافيار لم أكن أعرف
ما هي السيارة الجميلة وليست ما أنا عليه  يمكنني
إخبارك الآن أن
هذه الأشياء
تجعلك غير سعيد ، من
الجيد امتلاك المال ولكن المال ليس
كل شيء ، لقد
جئت من
فقير جدًا جدًا إلى ثري جدًا جدًا ويمكنني أن أخبرك أنه
يجب
عليك العثور على التوازن
[موسيقى]